قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي شن هجوما كبيرا في وادي سلوق
في جنوب لبنان بالتزامن مع تعرض عشرات
الاهداف لهجوم بالطائرات المقاتله
والمدفعيه وقال مراسل الجزيره ان طيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي شن اكثر من 20 غاره على
مناطق وبلدات متفرقه من جنوب لبنان وافاد
مراسلنا ان المقاتلات الاسرائيليه شنت 15
غاره على منطقه وادي السلوقي كما اغارت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه على بلده عيت الشعب
بينما تعرض محيط عشر بلدات لقصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي الى ذلك اعلن حزب الله عن
مهاجمته بالصواريخ تجمعا لجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شرق مستوطنه افن مناحم قباله
الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي شن غارتين على محيط بلده حول
ال جنوب لبنان كما رصدت الجزيره مشاهد
لتنفيذ طائرات اسرائيليه غاره جويه على
منطقه عيت الشعب جنوبي
البلاد قال قائد المنطقه الشماليه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي اوري جوردن ان الجيش على
اتم الجاهزيه والاستعداد على الحدود مع
لبنان اضاف جوردن خلال تفقده احدى الكتائب
على الحدود الشماليه ان الجيش ضرب اكثر من
150 خليه لحزب الله مسؤوله عن اطلاق
الصواريخ والمسيرات منذ بدء المواجهات
مشيرا الى ان العمل يتركز على تجريد حزب
الله من قدراته وشدد جوردن على ان العمل
مستمر من اجل توفير الامن بما يسمح باعاده
سكان المنطقه الشماليه الى
بيوتهم
الى شبكه مراسلين معنا من بلده رميش
جنوبيه لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم ومن الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره
جيفار البديري مرحبا بكما وسنبدا معك مازن
فرمي ولو تجمل لنا مجمل التطورات اليوم
وهي يبدو انها كثيره في منطقه
الجنوب في الواقع السي هو اليوم الاعنف من
حيث عدد الغار وطبيعه الغارات الاسرائيليه
والسلاح المستخدم من قبل المقاتلات
الحربيه التي نفذت حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من
25 غاره جويه على مناطق متفرقه في لبنان
تحديدا في جنوب لبنان التركيز الاساسي في
منطقه وادي سلوقي الذي يعتبر امتدادا
لوادي الحجير وهو ممر طبيعي في القطاع
الاوسط من جنوب لبنان ويربط ما بين الشريط
الحدودي وعمق جنوب لبنان ه هذه المنطقه
التي كان لها رمزيه خلال حرب 2006 حيث
تحولت الى ما كان يعرف على نطاق واسع هنا
في لبنان الى مقبره الدبابات الاسرائيليه
تم تنفيذ اليوم اكثر من 15 غاره في تلك
المنطقه ورصدنا اكثر من 30 صاروخا تم
اطلاقها باتجاه وادي الوقي هذه الغارات لم
تقف عند هذا الحد ولكنها امتدت الى محيط
بلده حوله قبل قليل رصدنا وسجلنا اكثر من
خمس غارات جو
من المقاتلات الحربيه نحن لم نعد نتحدث عن
المسيرات الاسرائيليه ولكن المقاتلات
الحربيه اغارت على محيط مدينه حوله وخلال
انتظار هذه الرساله المباشره السي قبل نحو
ربع ساعه اغارت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
المقاتله على بلده عيتا الشعب التي
نشاهدها في الخلفيه تم استهداف هذه البلده
ايضا بغاره جويه من خلال اطلاق صاروخ في
عمق البلده باتجاه المناطق السكنيه وال ل
بلده عيتا الشعب والتي بطبيعه الحال اخلاه
سكانها خلال الفتره الماضيه نتيجه تعرضها
بشكل دائم للصواريخ والقصف الاسرائيلي
السي كل هذه التطورات جاءت متسارعه ويمكن
الحديث عن ان الغارات الجويه هي الاعنف
منذ الثامن من اكتوبر عندما بدات المعارك
عند طول الخط الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان من
خلال العمليات التي ينفذها حزب الله ايضا
كان هنالك قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي استهدف اكثر
من ع بلدات هذا القصف استخدم من ناحيه
القذائف المدفعيه بالاضافه الى قنابل
يصفها ويؤكد الخبراء هنا بانها من القنابل
الفوسفوريه والقنابل الحارقه وتحديدا في
محيط وباتجاه بلده حوله كل هذه التطورات
الميدانيه ترافقت مع تاكيد رسمي لبناني من
خلال الحديث الذي ادلى به رئيس حكومه
تصريف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي للجزيره واكد
فيه بان لبنان الرسمي يسعى الى حلول
دبلوماسيه وهو يعتبر بان بدايه الحل هنا
عند الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان يرتبط بوقف
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه ومن
بعدها تطبيق القرارات الدوليه لاسما
القرار
1701 معتبرا بان اسرائيل هي من تعمد الى
خرق هذا القرار عبر العدوان الاسرائيلي
وخرق السياده اللبنانيه من خلال الغارات
من خلال القصف وايضا عمليات الاغتيالات
وبعجن القول بان ما ادلى به اليوم نجيب
مقاطي يتقاطع ويتماهى مع الخطاب الذي به
الامين العام لحزب الله والذي يربط هذه
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان مع كامل التطورات
في قطاع غزه جيفار البداري كيف تبدو
الاوضاع حيث انت تقفين ونقترب معك اكثر
كذلك من هذه التصريحات لمسؤولين عسكريين
وسياسيين وما يمكن ان تشي به بشان
المخططات الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بالجبهه
مع
لبنان من حيث نقف السي نستطيع سماع دوي
قصف اما بطائرات او قصف مدفعي سواء في
القطاعين الشرقي او الاوسط غارات لم تتوقف
اتجاه الجنوب اللبناني صفيرات الانذار دوت
قبل حوالي الربع ساعه في منطقه رمات نفتل
كما كانت قد دوت قبل ساعتين في منطقه
مسغاف عام وفي ساعات الصباح دوت على الاقل
في ثماني بلدات على طول خط الحدود تحديدا
من طبريه حتى كريات شموه اذا اي ولكن وفق
صحيفه معاريف الاسرائيليه فان اليوم هو
الاكثر حده وشده من حيث حجم الغارات التي
نفذت في داخل الجنوب اللبناني كما وصفه
قبل قليل الزميل مازن من حيث هذه الغارات
والتي بالطبع كان اعنف واقواها في وادي
السلوقي وفق المصادر الاسرائيليه تم تنفيذ
اكثر من 14 غاره على تلك ك المنطقه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعترف بانه من قام بتنفيذ هذه
الهجمات من خلال غارات مشتركه تم استخدام
الطائرات الحربيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وايضا قصف المدفعيه قال بانه قصف مباني
ومواقع عسكريه تابعه لحزب الله وانه
تستخدم هذه المواقع ل الوسائل القتاليه
سواء لتخزينها او لاستخدامها وان المنطقه
باكملها يستخدمها حزب الله ل قصف المدنيين
والجنود الاسرائيليين حسب وصف بيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولكن واضح اننا امام تصعيد
متواصل من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي ما
ذكرتيه قبل قليل السي اوري جوردن وهو قائد
المنطقه الشماليه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالامس خلال مناوره شارك فيها وقام
بالاطلاع على شكل هذه المناوره لاحدى
الكتائب في ال ما تعرف بلواء
288 قال بان الجيش الاسرائيلي على اتم
الجهز بمعنى انه جاهز لخوض الحرب على
لبنان ابتداء من هذه اللحظه
واان 150 خليه تم استهدافها منذ بدء
المعارك هنا في الثامن من اكتوبر وانه تم
السيطره او قصف الكثير من المواقع وهذه
الخلايا من قامت ب اطلاق المسيرات او
الصواريخ من داخل الجنوب اللبناني اتجاه
الجليل الاعلى على مدار خط الشريط الحدودي
شكرا اشكرك اشكركما جيفار البديري في
الجليل الاعلى ومدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم في رميش جنوب لبنان